♪
>> BEFORE WE START OUR PROGRAM,
A FEW WORDS ABOUT THE LAND ON
WHICH TODAY'S CEREMONY IS
TAKING PLACE.
YALE ACKNOWLEDGES THAT
INDIGENOUS PEOPLES AND NATIONS,
INCLUDING MOHEGAN, MASHANTUCKET
PEQUOT, EASTERN PEQUOT,
SCHAGHTICOKE, GOLDEN HILL
PAUGUSSETT, NIANTIC, AND THE
QUINNIPIAC AND OTHER ALGONQUIAN
SPEAKING PEOPLES, HAVE
STEWARDED
THROUGH GENERATIONS THE LANDS
AND WATERWAYS OF WHAT IS NOW
THE
STATE OF CONNECTICUT. WE HONOR
AND RESPECT THE ENDURING
RELATIONSHIP THAT EXISTS
BETWEEN
THESE PEOPLES AND NATIONS AND
THIS LAND.
THANK YOU, AND PLEASE ENJOY THE
PROGRAM.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DAVID EVANS: MR. PRESIDENT, I
HAVE THE HONOR TO PRESENT
CANDIDATES FROM BERKELEY
COLLEGE
FOR THE BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN
YALE COLLEGE. WHEN THEY HAVE
BEEN RECOMMENDED BY THE FACULTY
OF YALE COLLEGE AND APPROVED BY
THE CORPORATION, DEAN CHUN WILL
ASK YOU BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT TO
CONFER UPON THEM THESE DEGREES.
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> BY THE AUTHORITY VESTED IN
ME, I
SHALL CONFER UPON YOU THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN YALE
COLLEGE WHEN DESIGNATED BY THE
DEAN, AND SHALL THEN ADMIT YOU
TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
ELLEN MARGARET ANDREWS
THE BANNER BEARER OF BERKELEY
COLLEGE.
RACHEL COILE
AND
AMY ZHANG
THE PROCESSION MARSHALS OF
BERKELEY COLLEGE.
PRADHI VINAYAK AGGARWAL
COLIN ANTHONY BACIOCCO
JENIFFER LETICIA BANUELOS
SNL
OISHANI BASUCHOUDHARY
NEHA BHATT
MADELYN LYDIA BLANEY
KELVIN KOBINA BROBBEY
GRACE Q. CHEN
ALLISON SEONG-YEON CHUN
EDUARDO CUSTODIO LEAL
JAMES FOSTER DUNN
MICHELLE ERDENESANAA
DANIELLE ANN ESPOSITO
KELSEY OLYA EVANS
ABIGAIL VIRGINIA FORTIER
TOMEKA MICHELLE FRIESON
WILLIAM J. GALLAGHER
OHSHUE SHANE GATANAGA
JOAN A. GOMEZ-AGUILAR
DANIELLE KAYE HARRIS
LYDIA BROSS HILL
JULIAN DESHAUN JOHNSON
CHARLOTTE ELEANOR KAVALER
CALEB HYUN KIM
ANANYA NAVIA VIJAYA
KUMAR-BANERJEE
SOOYONG KWON
CLAIRE ELIZABETH LAFFAN
OLIVIA LEIGH LEVIEUX
ALICE GUANG LI
BRIAN WEN MAO LIN
GENEVIEVE SUSKIND LIU
HENRY C. LIU
YIN TING DAVID LOONG
TIMOTHY LARSSON LUZ
ZEPEI MA
CAROLINE LEWIS MAGAVERN
ZEV A. MAYER
TANVI MIHIR MEHTA
HELENA MARIA MILEO
WILLIAM THAYER MITCHELL
BRYANNA ARIEL MOORE
LYNN VI NGUYEN
CHAZ JUKICHI OKADA
BRYAN Y. OLIVEIRA
QUSAY Q. OMRAN
DANIEL O'REILLY
ANTHONY M. ORR
BRYAN LU OWENS
ALLEGRA O. PANKRATZ
AMAR H. PATEL
KATHRYN ORA PATON
ALLADIA KALI FAKIR PATTERSON
NATHAN HENRI PAUMIER
VICTORIA ISABEL QUINTANILLA
BRIAN REYES
ANDREW ST. CLAIR RICHARDS
MARISSA RIVERA
DAUD SHAD
VERONICA LETICIA SOSA
WILLIAM ARTHUR SUSSMAN
MARY MARTINOVNA TATE
WASHAKIE SHIGEO TIBBETTS
AUSTIN ZONG TUAN
ANISA A. VASHI
IRENE VÁZQUEZ
CANDICE WANG
MICHAEL JAMES ENGLISH WHALEN
ANDY M. XIE
ANNIE JINGYAN YANG
MARY JACQUELINE YAP
JOANNA CAROLINE ZUKIN
AND THE GRADUATES
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
TILMAN FREDERICK BARTELSMEYER
JENNA MARIE KAUFFMAN
AYUN IRENE KIM
JOANNA SIBONGI-NKOSI MASIYIWA
CHASTE TURIKUNKIKO GABA NIWE
TREVOR KYLE PASSMORE
SEAN-MICHAEL JOSEPH PIGÉON
ISABELLA TENG
ELYSE RUTH VANDERWOUDE
HANNAH LEE MARQUIS WOOD
CONGRATULATIONS BERKELEY CLASS
OF 2021!
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, I HAVE THE
HONOR
TO PRESENT CANDIDATES FROM
PAULI
MURRAY COLLEGE FOR THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN YALE
COLLEGE. WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN
RECOMMENDED BY THE FACULTY OF
YALE COLLEGE AND APPROVED BY
THE
CORPORATION, DEAN CHUN WILL ASK
YOU BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT TO
CONFER UPON THEM THESE DEGREES.
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> BY THE AUTHORITY VESTED IN
ME, I
SHALL CONFER UPON YOU THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN YALE
COLLEGE WHEN DESIGNATED BY THE
DEAN, AND SHALL THEN ADMIT YOU
TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
SEVERYN KUSHMELIUK
BANNER BEARER FOR PAULI
MURRAY COLLEGE.
LINCOLN THATCHER BERKLEY
AND
ILEANA SOPHIA VALDEZ
PROCESSION MARSHALS OF PAULI
MURRAY COLLEGE.
MAURO ACEVES-ACOSTA
AAKSHI AGARWAL
ALYA KHALEEL AHMED
AMER AHMAD AL-HIYASAT
AHMED ALI ALLAWI
KRISTA NAOMI ARELLANO
EKREM MELIH AYHAN
JACKSON ROBERT BANDOW
IHIRWE ORNELLA BAYIGAMBA
ADRIAN MICHAEL BEBENEK
HANNA LORRAINE BLANKEMEIER
MICHAEL P. BLICHER
SAM ISAAC KAIM BRAKARSH
BRANDON RONALD CHAMBERS
FELICIA CHANG
MICHAEL Y. CHANG
JAMES JOSEPH CHECK, JR.
PEI HUA CHEN
ESTHER YUNA CHOI
RYLEY DREW CONSTABLE
HUNTER RYAN CONTOS
LUKAS ROBERT COREY
CHRISTIAN RYAN CROPP
GAOLE DAI
KIRAN MATTHEW DAMODARAN
JOHN BASSEL SAMEH DAOUD
DANIEL JOSEPH DIPRIMIO
AMELIA LYNN DRAKE
YARA NOUR EL-KHATIB
MATTHEW J. ERICKSON
LUCAS CURRY FERRER
HEATHER JANE FOSTER
CHRIS EUGENE FOWLER, JR.
MILLA JUSTINE HANS FREEMAN
KEVIN PAUL GALLAGHER, JR.
YASHEEN GAO
GRIFFIN DOUGLAS GHARRITY
PATRYCJA ANETA GORSKA
JORDAN A. GRODE
LEILA A. HALLEY-WRIGHT
SAMUEL SEUNGHYUN HAN
KEVIN T. HONG
SARAH ANNE JORDAN
ALEXANDER THOMAS JULICHER
NAASEY ADDOBA KANKO ARTHUR
NASH DORIS BONFIELD KEYES
TASNIA KHAN
ALEXANDER KIROV
JACQUELYN ELIZABETH KNOBELSDORF
KATHERINE HYPATIA KUSHNER
JULIA MORGAN LEATHAM
KYOUNG A. VIOLA LEE
JUSTIN WEAVER LILLEY, JR.
CLAUDIA ALLEGRA LOIACONO
TESSA VIOLET MALONE
DANIELLE NICOLE MARTIN
RICHARD MOLU MBOUOMBOUO
KATHRYN SALLIE MIYAWAKI
ANAHEED LAHL MOBARAKI
SARAH MICHELE MONAHAN
HANNAH RAE MORENO
EMMA JOAN MUELLER
OSARIEMEN PRICLLIA OGBEMUDIA
JUDE ANTHONY ONG
NATALIE DORZEIDE ORNER
MITCHELL BENJAMIN OSTROW
JOSHUA GLENN PALMER
ROWAN MACKENZIE PALMER
YO HAN PARK
RYAN PATRICK PARKEY
AMANDA LLOYD PATTERSON
HUI EN SHANNON PHUAH
KAITLYNN TAYLOR PINEDA
JORDAN J. POWELL
ELIZABETH ANNE QIAN-WANG
KESHAV ADITYA RAGHAVAN
ANDREW PAUL REARDON
STEVEN M. REILLY
EMILY M. RICHARDS
CESAR AGUSTO RODRIGUEZ
EMMA L. RUOHONIEMI
MAXWELL NADDAFF SAHLINS
KEVIN SANAYCELA
ANTHONY ENRIQUE DANI SARKISS
LYDIA BENNETT SHAW
RENEE ANNA SU
KATHERINE WENXI SUN
BENJAMIN KYLE TILLINGER
MICHELLE KRISTINA TONG
GABRIEL ANTHONY VASQUEZ
NICHOLAS LANDON WADE
DANIEL ZHENGHAN WANG
SKYE DE LA VERGNE WARD
LAURA LEE WAYLAND
AMIRA KALI WILLIAMS
TIFFANY WONG
REESE MAXWELL WYNN
JONATHAN ALEX XU
HIU LAM VANESSA YAN
SEAN ANDREW YI
CLAIRE KELLY ZALLA
YI ZENG ZHANG
ANGELA F. ZHAO
SOPHIA ZHAO
AND THE GRADUATES PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY PATRICK BROWN
MATON CUTLER, MARLY CLAIRE
JAY JOHN
MUCH LOVE CONGRATULATIONS TO
THE CLASS OF PAULI MURRAY
COLLEGE!
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> MR. PRESIDENT, I HAVE THE
HONOR TO PRESENT CANDIDATES
FROM
DAVENPORT COLLEGE FOR THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN YALE
COLLEGE. WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN
RECOMMENDED BY THE FACULTY OF
YALE COLLEGE AND APPROVED BY
THE
CORPORATION, DEAN CHUN WILL ASK
YOU BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT TO
CONFER UPON THEM THESE DEGREES.
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> BY THE AUTHORITY VESTED IN
ME, I SHALL CONFER UPON YOU THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN YALE
COLLEGE WHEN DESIGNATED BY THE
DEAN, AND SHALL THEN ADMIT YOU
TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
JASON BRADLEY CAMPE
AND
EDA NAZ DINÇ
THE BANNER BEARERS OF DAVENPORT
COLLEGE.
CHELSEA NICOLE ILARDE
AND
ALYSSA JISU YOON
THE PROCESSION MARSHALS OF
DAVENPORT COLLEGE
AYODIMEJI OREOLUWA ABIOLA
JOAN CHIKA AGOH
CAMERON JAMES FISHER ALLEN
ROHAN SANGAMESH ANGADI
BABAK BADIEY
JESSICA YOONJU BAE
CLAY ANDREW BAILEY II
STEVEN DENNIS BARBEE
ALEXANDRA A. BAUMAN
AMEERA AHMED ELIZABETH BILLINGS
VICTORIA BONANO
ROBERT ANTHONY BRINKMANN
JOSHUA COLLIER BROOKS
NICOLE ERIN PRESGRAVE BRUSSEL
FARIA
MAXWELL G. BU
NATALIA CASTELLANOS
GONZALEZ
XIAFANGZHOU CHAO
ALAN CONG-XI CHEN
JULIA C. CHERTKOF
GRAYLEN RAY CHICKERING
ARIEL ELENA CLAXTON
DANIELLE ALEXIS COLLINS
SEKOU LI CONDE
PATRICK LAWRENCE CONTE
NICHOLAS RYAN DAHL
COSETTE ELIZABETH DAVIS
AMY C. DELABRUERE
LAUREN NICOLE DRYSCH
JENESIS VICTORIA DURAN
NATHALIE ANNE MARIE EID
EPONGUE WEI-DIKAKI EKILLE
NOAH DAVID GERSHENSON
CHLOE ALEXANDRA
HELLER
HENDERSON EDWARD HEUSSNER CALEB
CHRISTOPHER JAMES HLADCZUK
ALEXANDER WEST HISER HOBAN
LUCAS JOACHIM HOLTER
EMILY ROSE HOWELL
AMANDA IBAÑEZ
ABDULLA EBRAHIM MOHAMED AHMED
JANAHI
CONOR W.K. JOHNSON
NIKITA JOSHI
HASNA SAEEDA KARIM
ANGELE CHRISTIAN KELLY
JONATHAN GEORGE KRAFT
MORGAN ELLIE LAWSON
ALEXIS K. LAZOR
BU LIU
NICHOLAS MORAN MACNAB
CANNING LIVIA MALKIN
DANIEL JAMES MARSH
GEMA MARTINEZ CASTILLO
ETHAN DAVID MCBRIDE
WILLIAM FRANCIS MCGAHAN II
BRYAN MENDOZA
CHRISTIAN A. MILIAN-SANTIAGO
MUHAMMAD IMRAAN MUNSHI
PETER HOWARD NEUGEBAUER
ANNE COOPER NIELDS
ORLANDO MCMILLAN NIXON
ONYEDIKACHI ONUOHA
MATTHEW HOLMAN PEEL
MEGAN LEIGH QUIMBY
MAYA HALEY RAIFORD COHEN
RAJ K. RAMNANI
KATELYN EILEEN REESE
DANIEL THOMAS ROBINSON
KATERINA PAOLA ROBLES
ROBA SABAWI
MATTHEW PHILLIP SÁENZ
NIAM M. SHAH
NEELAM IYER SHAIKH
IRAM AFRIEN SHARIEFF
LAUREN HALLIE SINGER
TALIA ANNE PEARLMAN SOGLIN
KEVIN X. TANG
SYDNEY RICHELLE TERROSO
CAITLIN ELISABETH TYCZ
DIVINE IHUAKU UCHEGBU
RYAN PATRICK VOLLMER
ISABEL SKYE WANNER
JASON NATHANIEL WEINSTEIN
KESI K. WILSON
JACCARANDA PETROS WOLDEMARIAM
NATHAN SHAW WU
ANGELA YOO
FLORENTIN AUDLEY ZANDER
CONGRATULATIONS DAVENPORT
CLASS OF 2021!
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> MR. PRESIDENT, I HAVE THE
HONOR
TO PRESENT CANDIDATES FROM
BENJAMIN FRANKLIN COLLEGE FOR
THE BACHELOR'S DEGREES OF YALE
COLLEGE. WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN
RECOMMENDED BY THE FACULTY OF
YALE COLLEGE AND APPROVED BY
THE
CORPORATION, DEAN CHUN WILL ASK
YOU BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT TO
CONFER UPON THEM THESE DEGREES.
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> BY THE AUTHORITY VESTED IN
ME, I
SHALL CONFER UPON YOU THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN YALE
COLLEGE WHEN DESIGNATED BY THE
DEAN, AND SHALL THEN ADMIT YOU
TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
TYLER JOSEPH JANSEN
BANNER BEARER, BENJAMIN
FRANKLIN COLLEGE.
BEAMLAK SHIMELIS ASHENAFI
ABIGAIL SAMANTHA ESWARAKUMAR
MARSHALS FOR THE PROCESSION OF
FRANKLIN COLLEGE
CAMARA IFE AARON
WASIL S. AHMED
VICTORIA DAWN ANDREW
PAUL ST. AUBYN ATKINSON, JR.
THALIA BAEZA MILAN
JAYLEN RUSSELL BAILEY
STEPHANIE YOUNG BANG
SARAH ELIZABETH BASKIN
KIRAN MIRANDA BAUCOM
CRISTINA PAZ BERMUDEZ
EVAN CHRISTOPHER BLASY
IVANA BOZIC
JORDAN CAREY
MINA CEZAIRLI
T. VICTORIA CHEN
COLTON FORD CONLEY
JASON LOUIS CONTINO
ISABEL SILVA CORPUS
LAUREN NICOLE CUETO
EMMA ROSE DESROCHERS
BENJAMIN CLIFFORD LEE DORMUS
FRED JUNIOR EBONGUE MAKOLLE
AYAH AYMAN ELMANSY
MADELEINE M. FREEMAN
TONY GAO
CHARLES HARRISON GARDNER
ANGELA ZHINING GONG
CAROLINA SOFIA GONZALEZ ZAPATA
SPENCER CHASE HAGAMAN
MENRETT MORGAN WAGDY
HANNA GHATTAS
AMANDA DEBRA HARTZELL
MAXIMILIAAN PIET C. HIMPE
OONA O'NEILL HOLAHAN
SYDNEY LAURYN HOLMES
MINA GRACE HUGHES
SUNG WOOK ARTHUR HWANG
CHRISTOPHER IRSFELD
ISABEL ELISE JOHNSON
JIYOUNG KANG
LEO KHAZAN
MIHIR KHUNTE
KELSEY GRACE KISSANE
JESSICA LING KONG
ISABEL MOHANE KOOLIK
MIMI KOSTOSKA
SYLVIA ELIZABETH KRYSZCUK
MAKAYLA TERÈSE LARONDE-KING
OLIVIA MARGARET LEE
SASHA D. LEE
SARA MELANIE LEWIS
KATHARINE LI
SHANNON ROSS LINDER
LAUREN ELISE LO COCO
LAYLA LOPEZ
MELAT GENENE LULSEGED
ADAM JEFFREY MADIEVSKY
GUNASHEIL MANDAVA
FREDERIC-LOUIS ZACHARY MONTAS
TALIA NASH COON MORISON-ALLEN
LIVIU MOSNOI
JULIETTE CATHERINE NEIL
IRAGI CHRIST-VIE NKERA
EMMA CAROLINE OSBORNE
JOSEPH ERIC OSTUNO
ZI XIN OU
JOSEPH QUINLAN PECK
PATRICK MICHAEL PERRY
THOMAS JAMES POSTIGLIONE
CAROLINE ELIZABETH PRYOR
KATHRYN PUNDYK
MICHAEL BERNARD PURVEY, JR.
ALDO EUGENIO QUEVEDO
CINDY WANER REN
IMANI NIKIYA RICHARDSON
LOGAN PENN RIVERS
MEERA ARIELLE ROTHMAN
ZACHARY AUSTIN RUDNER
ABEERA SAEED
ISABEL GRACE SANDS
FRANCESCO MARIO CARLO SCARPETTA
ISAIAH MARTIN SCHRADER
JONATHAN MICHAEL SCHWARTZ
VIENNA GLORIA SCOTT
BENJAMIN DAVID SHELLEY
DONOVAN JOSEPH SLATER
ALEXA JENNIFER STANGER
PAUL PHILIP STANKEY
FAITH MEREDITH VASQUEZ
TRICIA VIVEROS
GWENDOLYN MAYA WALLACE
KATHLEEN SEGOVIA WELLS
LISA LIU WU
AMANDA WEI ZHANG
NAMRA ZULFIQAR
AND OUR GRADUATES
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
YIYUAN FANG
RYAN HAYGOOD
GABRIEL YUSUKE HOSHINO
BRUNO JEDNACAK
JOANNE EUNYOUNG KWAK
LUCAS TEKLEMARIAM
THEODORE SAMUEL PRITZKER VLOCK
PERRY PI YU XIN
CONGRATULATIONS BENJAMIN
FRANKLIN!
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> SO TO THE STUDENTS OF THE
CLASS OF
2021 AND THEIR PARENTS,
FAMILIES, AND FRIENDS LOOKING
ON
FROM AROUND THE GLOBE: WE
GATHER
TO RECOGNIZE THE EXTRAORDINARY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF ALL OF YOU
WHO HAVE WORKED SO HARD TO
COMPLETE YOUR PROGRAMS OF
STUDY.
WE SALUTE YOUR EFFORT, YOUR
DILIGENCE, YOUR TALENT, AND
YOUR
INTELLECT. WE ALSO JOIN YOU IN
EXPRESSING GRATITUDE FOR ALL
WHO
HAVE SUPPORTED YOU IN THESE
ENDEAVORS: YOUR FAMILIES AND
FRIENDS, TEACHERS, AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE YALE COMMUNITY.
CONGRATULATIONS, CLASS OF 2021!
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> HELLO CLASS OF 2021!
I'M BRYAN OWENS,
YOUR CLASS SECRETARY.
FOUR YEARS HAVE GONE BY IN THE
BLINK OF AN EYE. WE'VE MADE SO
MANY MEMORIES, FROM THE
FIRST-YEAR SNOWBALL FIGHT ON
OLD
CAMPUS RIGHT HERE, TO THE 2019
YALE-HARVARD GAME, WHICH WE WON
IN DOUBLE OVERTIME, TO THE LATE
NIGHTS, WHETHER
THEY BE IN THE LIBRARY STUDYING
FOR AN EXAM OR IN THE COMMON
ROOM TALKING WITH OUR
SUITEMATES AND FRIENDS.
ALTHOUGH OUR SENIOR YEAR
EXPERIENCE WAS CERTAINLY NOT A
TRADITIONAL ONE, THE CLASS OF
2021 MADE THE BEST OF THE
SITUATION. WHEN WE LEAVE YALE
IN
JUST A FEW DAYS, WE WILL LEAVE
WITH MEMORIES AND FRIENDSHIPS
THAT LAST A LIFETIME.
HERE'S TO THE CLASS OF 2021.
WE DID IT!
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> CLASS OF 2021, GOOD
AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS SKYE WARD, AND I AM
A
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
ORGANIZED CLASS DAY, WHICH WILL
AIR ON YOUTUBE TOMORROW AT 2:30
P.M. TWO MINUTES BEFORE 2:30,
AT
2:28 P.M., A SPECIAL PIECE
WRITTEN BY CLASS DAY SPEAKER,
ROBERT LOPEZ, WILL BE PLAYED
FROM HARKNESS TOWER, SO KEEP
YOUR EARS OPEN. IF YOU HAVEN'T
ALREADY DECORATED A FUNNY HAT
FOR CLASS DAY, IT'S NOT TOO
LATE! IN FACT, ON YOUR SEAT
TODAY, YOU RECEIVED A CLASS DAY
2021 HAT THAT YOU MIGHT WANT TO
USE FOR THAT PURPOSE. YOU'LL
ALSO FIND A GIFT BAG, WHICH
INCLUDES ITEMS THAT REPRESENT
LONGSTANDING CLASS DAY
TRADITIONS, AS WELL AS OTHERS
THAT ARE NEW AND UNIQUE TO THE
CLASS OF 2021. IN ADDITION TO
THE CLASS DAY SPEAKER,
TOMORROW'S PROGRAM ALSO
INCLUDES
REMARKS BY MEMBERS OF OUR CLASS
WHO HAVE PUT TOGETHER
OUTSTANDING ORIGINAL SPEECHES.
AND, BECAUSE CLASS DAY IS ABOUT
ALL OF US, YOU'LL SEE YOUR
PHOTOGRAPHS AND VIDEO
REFLECTIONS THROUGHOUT
TOMORROW'S PROGRAM.
CONGRATULATIONS, CLASS OF 2021,
AND SEE YOU AT CLASS DAY!
[ APPLAUSE ]
DEAN CHUN: CLASS OF 2021,
CONGRATULATIONS!
I AM SO HAPPY
TO BE WITH YOU AND CELEBRATE
WITH YOU TODAY. GRADUATING IS A
GREAT ACCOMPLISHMENT, ONE OF
THE
MOST IMPORTANT ONES OF YOUR
LIFE. IF YOU THINK BACK TO WHEN
YOU FIRST ARRIVED ON CAMPUS, NO
ONE COULD HAVE IMAGINED THAT
YOU
WOULD LIVE THROUGH A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC BEFORE REACHING THIS
MOMENT. BUT YOU DID, AND THANKS
TO YOUR STRENGTH AND
PERSEVERANCE, THIS MOMENT HAS
FINALLY COME. I AM
HONORED TO RECOGNIZE ALL THE
WORK THAT YOU HAVE
DONE TO GET HERE, MUCH OF IT
WITH THE SUPPORT OF YOUR FAMILY
AND FRIENDS. TODAY IS YOUR
DAY, AND IT IS THEIRS TOO.
TODAY IS A DAY FOR LOOKING
BACK WITH PRIDE AT EVERYTHING
YOU HAVE ACCOMPLISHED AND ALL
THE GOALS YOU HAVE REACHED. OF
COURSE IT BRINGS SOME SADNESS,
TOO, NOW THAT YOU ARE ENDING
YOUR BRIGHT COLLEGE YEARS. BUT
TODAY IS A COMMENCEMENT, A
BEGINNING, SO NOW, AS YOU LOOK
TO THE DAYS AND YEARS AHEAD,
THINK OF THE NEW ACHIEVEMENTS
AND OPPORTUNITIES IN FRONT OF
YOU. AND LOOK AROUND AS WELL,
TO
REMIND YOURSELF OF THE
EXCELLENT
COMPANY JOINING ON THIS NEW
BEGINNING ━ YOUR FRIENDSHIPS
FORMED AT YALE.
TOMORROW YOU WILL CELEBRATE
CLASS DAY ━ A TRADITION
STRETCHING BACK 150 YEARS IN
YALE COLLEGE HISTORY. I AM
EXCITED TO  WATCH THE VIRTUAL
PROGRAM ALONGSIDE YOU AND TO
ON MONDAY WE CAN LOOK FORWARD
TO PRESIDENT SALOVEY'S
COMMENCEMENT ADDRESS.
I AM
COMMENCEMENT ADDRESS. I AM
GRATEFUL TO THE CLASS DAY
COMMITTEE, TO THE SENIOR CLASS
COUNCIL, TO
THE UNIVERSITY SECRETARY'S
OFFICE, TO YOUR COLLEGE HEADS
AND DEANS, AND TO EVERYONE WHO
CONTRIBUTED TO MAKING THE
SPECIAL EVENTS OF THIS WEEKEND
POSSIBLE. AND I'M MOST
APPRECIATIVE TO YOU, FOR ALL
THAT YOU HAVE BROUGHT TO YALE━-
AND WILL NOW BRING OUT INTO THE
WORLD WITH YOU. AGAIN, CLASS OF
2021, CONGRATULATIONS!
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪